- If you had to be stuck in
a room with just one person
and it wasn't your wife or kids,
- Wasn't my wife or kids,
do my wife and kids exist?
- Oh, that's an important question.
'Cause I know where you're going.
(Kelly laughs)
- Because I wanna know,
is sex on the table?
Is sex not on the table?
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Wait a minute.
- If I'm in a room,
- I need to know.
- I just changed my person
if sex is on the table.
(Sterling laughs)
- You know what I'm saying?
- I was like thinking survival,
and now I'm like, "Wait,
wait, wait, wait."
- Right.
There's another kind of survival.
- No, it's anything...
(Kelly laughs)
(audience applauds)
It's humanity and it's fine.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
Let's say none of our families exist.
You're just stuck in a room
and you have to choose someone.
- All right, well, okay.
If sex isn't on the table,
I'm gonna pick my best
friend, Philip Grant,
who I've known since I was five years old.
(Kelly gasps)
- That's awesome.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah. Since kindergarten.
- Now, can this person
help you out?
Like, you know, are they a survivalist?
- He is.
- Okay.
- I'm not a super handy guy.
- But he is like
DIY all day long, so he can fix stuff.
- Okay.
- He's a good cook too.
- You'd pick him and he'd
pick someone else? (laughs)
- No.
(Kelly laughs)
'Cause I can entertain.
- You don't seem helpful.
(both laughing)
That's amazing.
- I'm good for a chuckle.
- That's amazing.
- Yeah, so that would be him.
If sex was on the table,
I'd pick somebody else.
- Yeah, me too.
(audience laughs and applauds)
So, if sex were on the table,
definitely that's not on the table.
I honestly think-
- Where'd you go?
- I'm gonna pick my sister.
Because this is why, we didn't
actually grow up together.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- We didn't, dysfunctional
American family.
Anyway, but we're so similar
and I think I'd pick her
just because, I think,
we're able to be very honest
with each other.
- Yes.
- Like, "Look, I need a minute
- Yeah.
- without you in it."
- Right.
- You know what I'm saying?
- Me and my free, yes.
But also like, she's really,
we can both build fire.
We can both do, we're
like survivalist people.
- Really? Were you a Girl Scout?
- Yes, I was a Girl Scout.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yes.
(audience applauds)
I love all of that.
I have every book.
If you ever came in my house,
you'd probably be like,
"She might have a problem."
- No, but like-
- I think it's fun.
I love "Biosphere."
I'm totally into this kind
of concept for a movie show.
Everything.
- So basically you're
telling me if it happens,
I'm coming to your house.
- I tell all my friends
'cause none of those (beep) prepared.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
I'm like, yeah.
I'm like, "Everybody's
gonna come to my house
so I gotta have enough for everybody."
- Yeah.
- But, yeah, no, I'm that
person you'd want to be stuck
in a room 'cause I'm pretty handy.
- Okay.